Guten Tag.
Hallo, guten Tag.
Ich bin zuständiger als hier auf diese Station.
Und würde gerne mit Ihnen diese Gespräche führen.
Wenn Sie Fragen haben, bitte sagen Sie einfach Bescheid.
Alles verständlich.
Erst mal, wehe heißen Sie bitte?
Ich heiße Anna Schmidt.
Könnten Sie Ihren Namen bestrabieren?
Welchen? Vor oder nach Namen?
Beide geht.
Anna mit A, AA.
Und?
Schmidt wie Schmidt mit DT.
Alles klar.
Frau Schmidt, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin geboren am 1. Mai 1954.
Noch mal bitte.
1. Mai 1954.
Also 68 Jahre alt.
Ja, 68.
Was kann ich für Sie tun? Was führt Sie zu uns?
Ich habe Probleme mit der Luft.
Ich bekomme keine Luft.
Ich kriege keine Luft.
Sie leiden an Luftschnut.
Wie zurzeit können Sie bis Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Oder brauchen Sie ein Sauerstoff?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Das müssen Sie beurteilen.
Sie nicht aushalten.
Ich kann Ihnen gerne ein Sauerstoff geben.
Sauerstoff geben.
Sie können gerne Sauerstoff haben.
Ich kann Ihnen Sauerstoff geben.
Wir könnten Ihnen Sauerstoff anhängen.
Was geht auch?
Was geht auch über die Nasenbrille?
Sauerstoff anhängen.
Sie können von einem Sauerstoff.
Aber kann ich Ihnen Sauerstoff geben?
Ich glaube, das sagt man nicht.
Sie können, oder brauchen Sie Sauerstoff?
Wir könnten Ihnen, was sagt man das eigentlich?
Ich will nur wissen, ob man das so sagen kann.
Ich kann Ihnen Sauerstoff geben.
Wir machen weiter.
Ich halte das noch aus.
Wir können Ihre
Zeichen messen.
Diese Luftnot.
Seit wann haben Sie die?
Ich habe schon lange, wenn ich Streppensteige Luftnot.
Jetzt habe ich aber auch in Ruhe Luftnot.
Im Ruhe seit wann?
Das geht schon seit Monaten.
Die letzten
paar Tage kann ich gar nichts mehr machen.
Weil ich so starke Luftnot habe.
Früher hatten Sie nur bei Belastung?
Vorher habe ich das immer nur gemerkt.
Wenn ich mich körperlich angestrinkt habe.
Jetzt geht es nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist es zu Ende.
Das wird sehr schweißer.
Haben Sie auch Schmerzen?
Wie ist das?
Momentan.
Ich habe Luftnot.
Es ist eng.
Ich bitte von Schwesterin.
Ich werde die Schwesterin bitten.
Dass Sie ein EKG schreiben.
Genau.
Ich will das.
Diese enge Gefühle.
Wo befindet sich?
Auf meiner Brust.
Was für ein Schmerz.
Diese enge Gefühle.
Ich habe keinen Schmerz.
Ich habe nur enge Gefühle.
Wie stark?
Ein Engelgefühl.
Sie haben auch seit ein paar Tagen diese enge Gefühle.
Das habe ich auch wenig.
Ich körperlich anstrengen.
Diese Strahlen.
Diese enge Gefühle.
Ein anderer Seite.
Ein Engelgefühl.
Ein Brustkorb.
Sie wollen sagen, ob das ausstrahlt.
Das dürfen Sie nicht fragen.
Schmerzen strahlen aus.
Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Schmerzen.
Sie haben Engelgefühle.
Sie haben keine Schmerzen.
Sie haben einen Schmerz.
Ein Engelgefühl.
Leiden Sie an, zur Zeit?
Sputum.
Oder
Husten?
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
oder leiden Sie an, oder hatten Sie viel geschwitzen?
Noch mal wiederholen bitte. Haben Sie Nachtschweiß, Kaltschweiß?
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß? Haben Sie viel geschwitzt? Können Sie sagen, wenn Sie das Wort
geschwitzt benutzen, haben Sie viel geschwitzt oder Sie können sagen,
schwitzen Sie viel, okay? Haben Sie viel geschwitzt, schwitzen Sie viel oder
haben Sie Nachtschweiß, alles geht. Nein, ehrlich gesagt Doktor, ist mir nicht
aufgefallen. Auch nicht. Ist Ihnen übel oder haben Sie sich
erbrochen? Mir ist nicht übel und ich möchte nie wieder hören, haben Sie sich
erbrochen? Nie, haben Sie sich übergeben oder haben Sie erbrochen?
Also noch mal fragen bitte. Haben Sie erbrochen? Nein, habe ich nicht.
Oder war Ihnen nicht schwindelig? Ja, schwindel habe ich. Wenn ich mich anstrengen, habe ich
Schwindel auch. Seit wann haben Sie? Ich habe immer, wenn ich mich anstrengen, habe ich
Schwindel gehabt, aber jetzt habe ich auch Schwindel. Jetzt auch, wo ich hier sitze,
habe ich auch Schwindel und Luftnot. Sind Ihnen aufgefallen, Ohrsausen oder Kopfschmerzen?
Nein, Kopfschmerzen habe ich nicht. Ich höre auch noch recht gut.
Sehr gut. Dann gibt es bei Ihrem Vorgeschicht die wichtige Erkrankungen,
von denen ich wissen sollte oder leider die unter einer chronischen Krankheit
Was meinen Sie damit? Ich meine, Zuckerkrankheit oder erhöhte Blutdruck?
Zuckerkrankheit, ja. Ja, Zuckerkrankheit, ja Zuckerkrankheit. Seit wann haben Sie?
Ach, das weiß ich nicht. Schon lange. Zuckerkrankheit, ja, Blutdruck, ja. Ja, habe ich.
Auch schon lange oder seit wann wissen Sie? Schon lange, ich nehme schon lange Medikamente ein.
Hab ich schon Jahre. Welche Medikamente? Oh, welche Medikamente.
Also dann nehme ich ein, das Methoprolol, 50, zweimal am Tag, das Ramitril,
5 Milligramm, zweimal am Tag. Ramitril, wie viel bitte? 5. Dann nehme ich das Lerkanidipin,
10 Milligramm morgens, dann nehme ich das Atorvastatin, 40 Milligramm abends, dann nehme ich das
Xarelto, 20 Milligramm abends und dann nehme ich noch Thorazimit, 5 Milligramm morgens ein.
Haben Sie zurzeit Probleme beim Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang aktuell?
Ja, ich muss viel auf die Toilette, ich muss viel Wasser lassen.
Wie oft am Tag? Das ist unterschiedlich, aber ich muss sehr oft, ich muss so 3, 4 Mal am Tag und
ich muss auch zweimal in der Nacht raus. Zweimal in der Nacht, aber das ist mehr
grenzwert, das ist normal, aber am Tag, das kann viel sein. Könnten Sie ein Schätzen, wie viel Liter
scheiden Sie aus? Das kann ich Ihnen nicht sagen.
Haben Sie auch Handrank? Ja. Alles klar. Beim Stuhlgang haben Sie auch Probleme?
Nein, eigentlich nicht. Eigentlich klappt das ganz gut.
Sind Sie schon mal operiert? Frau Schmidt?
Operiert. Ja, ich wurde schon mal operiert und zwar haben die mich operiert am Arm und mit dem Arm haben
die etwas gemacht und sind am Arm und mit dem Arm mein Herz gegangen.
Die haben etwas am Arm und mein Arm gemacht und ich war wach. Das war eine Operation,
das ist schon 10 Jahre her. 10 Jahre. Etwas über Ihr Herz durchgeführt,
von Ihrem Arm eingeführt und wo da ein OP, ja, dann Sie wach waren.
Und was noch? Gab es Komplikationen? Nein, es gab eigentlich keine Komplikationen,
aber die haben das nach 2 Tagen diese Operation wiederholt.
Vor 2? Vor 10 Jahren. Nach 2 Tagen haben Sie diese Operation an meinen Arm,
was Sie gemacht haben mit dem Herz, haben Sie wiederholt. Ja. Es wurde 2 Mal durchgeführt.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt? Nein, die haben noch etwas gemacht.
Die haben noch mal mit Narkose, was an meinen Herzen gemacht vor 2 Jahren.
Die haben... Könnte es beipasst sein, vielleicht?
Nein, nein, nein. Da bin ich ins Krankenhaus und dann hatte ich auch starke Luftnot
und dann haben mich schlafen gelegt und Schock gemacht.
Schlafen gelegt? Was meinen Sie damit? Schlafen gelegt.
Die haben mich in den Schlaf gelegt und dann haben Sie einen Schock abgegeben.
Das war vor 2 Jahren.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten?
Welche Medikamente oder Nahrung?
Ich habe eine Laktose intoleranz, aber sonst habe ich keine Allergien.
Rauchen Sie, Frau Schmidt? Nein, ich habe auch nie geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol? Nein.
Noch nie? Oder hat man Sie getrunken früher?
Ja, bei den Gurtsagsfeiern zum Beispiel. Aber ganz selten.
Auch da versuche ich nicht zu trinken.
Ja, verstand ich.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen? Nein.
Jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen über Ihr Familien- und Sozialstatus.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben? Nein.
Leben Ihre Eltern noch? Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Oder sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben? Nein, die sind verstorben.
Das tut mir sehr leid. Darf ich fragen, woran Sie gestorben sind?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr genau.
Ich weiß nur, dass meine Mutter herzkrank war.
Wie alt war sie, als Sie gestorben? Meine Mutter.
Die war noch nicht so alt. Sie war 70.
Sie müssen sich vorstellen, ich bin 54, geboren habe ich gesagt.
Ich bin ja auch schon 68 Jahre alt.
Wenn von einer 68-Jährigen die Mutter gestorben ist,
dann müssen sie sagen, das ist normal, dass sie gestorben ist.
Die ist ja schon viel älter.
Meine Mutter war herzkrank, aber ich weiß nicht genau, was sie hatte.
Ja, und?
Der Vater?
Der ist ganz anderen am Alter gestorben.
Der Vater war alt.
Ich glaube, er ist eine Krankheit.
Mein Vater war eigentlich relativ gesund, er hatte nur einen Bluthochdruck.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ich habe drei Schwestern.
Sind Sie gesund?
Meine eine Schwester hat auch etwas am Herzen, die ist auch herzkrank.
Meine andere Schwester hatte schon einen Schlaganfall.
Die höchste Schwester ist eigentlich gesund.
Wie ist die aktuelle Situation?
Hat es Medikamentöse behandelt?
Das weiß ich nicht mehr.
So engen Kontakt haben wir nicht.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich war selbstständig.
Mit wem leben Sie?
Mit wem leben Sie geht es mit?
Mit wem leben Sie alleine?
Oder leben Sie, sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich frage immer so, wenn ich meine Patientin anmeste,
dann sage ich immer, Herr Sohn, sind Sie verheiratet?
Dann frage ich, lebt Ihre Frau noch?
Oder sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein, dann sage ich, leben Sie alleine?
Wenn Sie verheiratet, dann frage ich, lebt Ihr Mann noch?
Also nochmal.
Sind Sie verheiratet oder leben Sie alleine?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Und lebe mit meinem Mann zusammen, Gott sei Dank.
Sehr gut, das trägt mich.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe eine gesunde Tochter.
Wie schön.
War Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland oder haben Sie eine lange Reise gehabt?
Eine Menge Reise hatte ich nicht gehabt, nein.
Träbern Sie sportregelmäßig?
Nein, ich habe nicht gesagt.
Ich habe gesagt, nein.
Wollte Sie etwas Beschwerden hinzufügen?
Etwas vielleicht, dass ich mir entgangen bin.
Ja, ich habe eigentlich alles gesagt.
Ich habe wirklich Luftnoten, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich jetzt auch im Sitzen kaum Luft kriege.
Mir geht es ganz schlecht darunter.
Es ist so eng in der Brust.
Ich habe das Gefühl, das Herz schlägt so schnell,
dass es mir fast explodiert.
Herr Frazen, meine Sie?
Das schlägt schnell, ja.
Haben Sie Schwellung bei Ihren Beinen?
Ja, meine Beine sind immer etwas dicker vor Tagsüber.
Nachts wird es besser.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe, sind ich wieder schlanker.
Im Laufe des Tages werden die immer etwas dicker, meine Beine.
Aber vor allem morgens, ne?
Ja, morgens nicht.
Wenn ich morgens aufstehe, dann ist es etwas besser.
Dann sind die nicht so dick.
Im Laufe des Tages wird es wieder ein bisschen dicker.
Können Sie flach legen?
Herr Doktor, momentan kann ich gar nicht legen,
weil ich so starke Luftnot habe.
Wie viele Kissen brauchen Sie zum Schlafen?
Ich schlafe schon fast im Sitzen.
So starke Luftnot habe ich momentan, die letzten paar Tage.
Sonst normalerweise liege ich ganz normal im Bett
und habe jetzt keinen sehr hohen Kissen.
Ich kann hoch nicht schlafen.
Aber früher konnten Sie normal legen und schlafen.
Nur seit paar Tagen.
Richtig.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie auch etwas bemerkt, dass diese Luftnot lindert?
Nein.
Momentan kann ich mir nicht helfen,
deswegen bin ich hierher.
Damit Sie mir helfen können.
Es gibt momentan nichts, was es lindert.
Sie haben das richtig gemacht, indem Sie ins Krankenhaus gekommen sind.
Jetzt werde ich bei Ihnen wie Teilparameter zeichnen
und Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Jetzt nochmal.
Jetzt werde ich wie Teilparameter zeichnen
und Sie körperlich untersuchen, geht nicht.
Jetzt werde ich wie Teilparameter messen.
Messen und Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Sehr gut.
Was meinen Sie mit wie Teilparameter, Herr Doktor?
Das verstehe ich leider nicht.
Ihre Beatmung, Herzfrequenz, Atemfrequenz, Fieber.
Nicht Beatmung, nicht Ihre Beatmung.
Beatmung wäre, wenn wir den Patienten manuell oder maschinell beatmen.
Ihre Atmung, also Ihre Atemfrequenz, Puls und die Sauerstoffsetigung.
Genau.
Nein, ich weiß, dass das schwer ist, aber Beatmung, nicht die Beatmung.
Ja, Atem.
Puls, Atemfrequenz, Puls, vor allen Dingen Sauerstoffsetigung und EKG.
Natürlich, wir haben schon gemacht ein EKG.
Okay.
Ich gehe bei Ihnen von einem Verdacht auf Herzinsuffizienz aus.
Was ist bei der Herzinsuffizienz, Herr Doktor?
Wenn Ihre Herz so überbelastet sind und nicht richtig funktioniert.
Was meinen Sie mit nicht richtig funktioniert?
Nicht gut punkten Ihre Blut zu ganz Körper nach ganz Körper.
Und Sie brauchen deswegen einige Untersuchungen durchführen bei Ihnen.
Nein, also die Herzinsuffizienz habe ich nicht ganz verstanden.
Das müssen Sie mir nochmal erklären.
Was meinen Sie mit der Herzinsuffizienz?
Herzinsuffizienz, wenn Ihr Herz nicht gut pumpt.
Nicht gut pumpt.
Ich sage jeden Tag zu meinen Patienten.
Die verstehen das nicht.
Die verstehen nur, Ihr Herz pumpt nicht gut.
Ihr Herz arbeitet nicht so gut.
Ihr Herz pumpt etwas weniger als es soll.
Das Herz pumpt nicht gut.
Herzinsuffizienz, Herr Frosch mit bedeutet Herzschwäche.
Herzschwäche.
Alles klar? Okay?
Alles klar.
Als Herzgeschenke am fangen.
Ich freue mich auf Sie.
Ja, ich bin sehr stolz.
Ich bin sehr stolz.
Nein, wir sind nicht stolz.
Wir haben uns gesagt, dass wir kurz nach dem
Rundverschleunigung haben.
Ja, das soll er jetzt während Erzien sagen gleich.
Wenn er jetzt die 13 vorstellt.
Okay?
Ich bin nämlich nur gerig, was er verstanden hat.
Okay, ich bin so weit.
Jusuf.
Moment, Jusuf.
Ich stehe auf, Jusuf.
Das ist natürlich dieses Krankheitsbild.
Das ist natürlich wie ein Chamäleon.
Das kann ja alles sein.
Das ist natürlich etwas, wenn man das in der Prüfung hat,
dann muss man wirklich alle Krankheitsbilder kennen,
was das machen kann.
Gelb?
Nicht wahr?
Okay.
Hallo Frau Oberersten.
Hat Sie eine kurze Zeit für mich?
Ja, gerne.
Frau Anna Schmidt,
18, 6-jährige Patientin.
Hat sich heute bei uns
mit
eine Düsbne vorgestellt.
Mit einer Düsbne sagt man nicht.
Stellt sich heute mit Düsbne bei uns vor.
Eine Düsbne, die ist nicht.
Eine Düsbne ist ein Oberbegriff.
Stellt sich mit Düsbne vor.
Stellt sich mit uns.
Also nochmal.
Stellt sich bei uns mit Düsbne vor.
Oder kam zu uns mit Düsbne.
Ja.
Kommt zu uns mit Düsbne.
Sehr gut.
Das ist super.
Die Beschwerden
seien schon lange.
Aber seit ein paar Tagen.
Die Beschwerden
seien schon lange nicht.
bestehend schon seit lange.
Bestehend schon seit lange.
Bestehend schon lange.
Aber würden Sie sich
seit ein paar Tagen
eine Düsbne machen?
Früher habe Frau Schmidt
nur unter Belastung
diese Luftnot habe.
Stopp.
Was heißt stopp?
Ein super perfekter Satz endet ganz schlecht.
Früher
habe Frau Schmidt
diese Beschwerden nur unter Belastung.
Aber jetzt auch im Ruhe.
Sehr gut.
Sie kann
nur beim Sitzen schlafen.
Sie kann momentan nur im Sitzen schlafen.
Nicht beim Sitzen.
Sie kann nur im Sitz schlafen.
Sie kann momentan nur im Sitz schlafen.
Sehr gut.
Nur im Sitz schlafen.
Aber auch ein Begleitzymtom.
Berichtet sie
Angina pectoris
vertigo.
Nein.
Was heißt angina? Schmerz. Pektoris heißt Brustschmerzen.
Ich kann mich erinnern, gesagt zu haben, dass ich keine Schmerzen in der Brust habe.
Keine angina Pektoris. Vorsicht mit dem Begriff.
Engelgefühl. Sie berichtet über Engelgefühl in der Brust.
Engelgefühl, Schwindel, Polacuri und Tennismus vesica.
Was ist das für ein Engelgefühl?
Handrang.
Sagen Sie doch einfach Handrang.
Inkontinent.
Engelkontinent ist etwas anderes.
Inkontinent ist, wenn man in die Hose macht.
Handrang ist, man muss ganz oft auf die Toilette.
Es drängt einen.
Inkontinent ist, wenn man das nicht halten kann.
Das hat sie ja nicht.
Sie hat nur den Drang.
Es drängt viel.
Das ist ja richtig.
Handrang.
Sie muss 5-10 mal am Tag zur Toilette gehen.
Nein, ich habe gesagt 4-mal.
3-4 mal am Tag.
Das stimmt nicht 5-10 Mal.
Ich habe gesagt 3-4 Mal am Tag und 2 Mal in der Nacht.
Ja.
Und ein Herzrasen und beim Ödem sind auch hier aufgefallen.
Ja, sehr gut.
Wir fragen nach Gusten,
Weber,
Kopfschmerzen,
Tinnitus
oder
Rudolfernens
an Vorerkrankungen.
Leider sie an Diabetes,
Militias, Arthéa,
Lipetonies schon lagen.
Und dagegen nimmt sie Metroprolol.
15 Milligramm, 2 Mal am Tag,
2-mal am Tag, 3-mal am Tag.
Nein, stopp.
Wie viel Milligramm Metroprolol habe ich gesagt?
15 Milligramm Metroprolol gibt es nicht.
Wenn Sie das sagen,
weiß der Prüfer schon, dass Sie keine Ahnung haben.
Metroprolol gibt es immer nur als 50er und als 100er.
Oder aber 47,95 Milligramm.
Das sind 200 Dosis Metroprolol.
50 und 100 oder 47,95.
Das sind zwei verschiedene Marken.
Metroprol-Suxenat sind 47,5.
Normales Metroprolol sind 50 Milligramm.
Ich habe 50, 2-mal am Tag.
Bitte keine 15, das gibt es nicht.
50,5.
Die niedrigste Dosierung von Metroprolol,
die im Krankenhaus geben ist,
50 Milligramm die Hälfte.
25 zum Beispiel.
Oder 47,5 die Hälfte.
Nur, dass Sie das wissen.
50 Milligramm, 50 Milligramm.
Metroprolol.
Alles klar, stimmt.
2-mal am Tag.
Und Ram, April, 5 Milligramm.
Ja.
Lerka, die Pinnen, einmal am Tag.
Zarelto, 20 Milligramm, einmal abends.
Was ist das?
Ja, Tora Semit, 5 Milligramm, einmal morgens.
Und es ist eine Laktosintoleranz bei ihr bekannt.
Keine Allergien bekannt auch.
Sie hat noch nicht geraucht.
Und Trinke, Alkohol, gelegentlich nur auf Feiern.
Sehr gut.
Kein Drogenkonsum.
Ihr Vater hatte Artealhypertonie.
Und Mutter hatte Herzkrankheiten.
Aber sie weiß nicht, was genau ist.
Und auch daran gestorben.
Ich habe 3 Geschwister.
Und eine hat auch ein Herzprobleme.
Aber...
Eine hat auch Herzprobleme oder ein Herzprobleme.
Ein Herzprobleme geht nicht.
Ein und mehr zahlt geht nicht.
Entweder sie hat ein Herzproblem oder sie hat Herzprobleme.
Haben Sie es verstanden?
Ja.
Und eine Schwester hatte Schlaganfall.
Und die andere ist gesund.
Es wurde bei ihr ein Corona-Angiografen.
Die andere ist für mich nicht genau.
Welche andere?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Was meinen Sie mit der anderen?
Die andere Operation.
Das ist oft, wenn die Patienten eine Herzkartett-Untersuchung haben.
Die Gefäße können nicht alle auf einmal machen.
Das reicht, wenn sie sagen, sie hatte vor 10 Jahren eine Herzkartett-Untersuchung.
Das Einzige, was sie hätten den Patienten fragen müssen,
ist damals bei diesem Eingriff, Eingriff, Intervention.
Wie hat sie gesagt, die Patienten denken, dass das Operation ist?
Das sagen sie mir auch immer.
Aber damit meinen die Herzkartett-Untersuchungen.
Wenn Sie die Patienten fragen, war das eine Herzkartett-Untersuchung?
Dann sagen sie, ja.
Dann hätten sie fragen müssen, die sind alt, die wissen das nicht.
Ist damals was gemacht worden?
Haben Sie einen Stand bekommen?
Oder ist in einem Ballon etwas aufgemacht worden?
Dann sagen die, ja.
Sie können Ihnen natürlich nicht sagen,
welches Gefäß gemacht worden ist.
Aber das haben Sie vergessen zu fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass eine Herzkartett-Untersuchung war.
Sie hätten Ihnen auch sagen können, nein,
ich habe eine Herzkartett-Untersuchung gemacht,
aber das war unauffällig.
Die haben damals gesagt, dass alles in Ordnung ist.
Man kann sagen, eine Herzkartett-Untersuchung
ohne pathologischen Befund zum Beispiel,
das wissen Sie jetzt nicht.
Das haben Sie nämlich nicht gefragt.
Wir müssen das nächste Mal fragen,
ist damals was gemacht worden?
Aber eine Herzkartett-Untersuchung ist genau richtig.
Das meinte ich damit.
Ich meinte die andere Operation,
schlafen, gelegt.
Was habe ich damit gemeint, mit schlafen gelegt?
Herzschritt nach Hause.
Nein, was heißt schlafen, gelegt?
Was heißt, jemand schlafen, gelegt?
Voll langsprachig.
Ja, eine Stilie, eine kurze, eine kurze Narkose haben die gemacht.
Jemand mit schlafen, gelegt heißt kurz Narkose.
Okay, kurz Narkose und Schockabgabe.
Was ist das? Das müssen Sie wissen.
Schockend.
Ja, was machen?
Eine Kardioversion.
Eine elektrische Kardioversion haben die gemacht.
Wir kommen da gleich.
Richtig, sehr gut.
Sie haben schlafen, gelegt.
So sagen die Patienten.
Sie haben schlafen, gelegt und haben ein Schockabgabe gegeben.
Dann wissen Sie ganz genau,
die hatte eine Kardioversion gehabt.
Woher wissen Sie noch,
dass es eine Kardioversion sein könnte?
Es gibt einen ganz kleinen Hinweis bei den Medikamenten.
Was nimmt Sie dann ab?
Was nimmt Sie dann ein?
Ciccerato.
Warum nimmt Sie Ciccerato ein?
Sie haben zum Beispiel die Patientin nicht gefragt,
als sie gesagt hat, Ciccerato,
müssen Sie sofort fragen.
Immer.
Warum nehmen Sie diese Blutverdünnung ein?
Manche wissen das,
manche wissen das nicht,
dass das noch meistens wissen.
Sie hätten mich fragen müssen.
Dann hätten Sie, die anamieren Sie, viel einfacher gehabt.
Warum nehmen Sie die Blutverdünnung ein?
Fürst auf, sagen Sie mal.
Warum könnte Sie Ciccerato einnehmen?
Was gibt es für Gründe?
Einmal?
Herzlichen Dank.
Nein?
letzten Mal. Varfarin und Xarelto niemals am Herzenfakt. Am Herzenfakt gibt es immer duale
antithrombozutere Medikamente. Eine orale Anticoagulation. Antithrombozutere Medikamente,
ASS, aspirin, Klopidogrel, Hasogrel, was gibt es noch, tika-grelo, okay, diese Medikamente. Nicht
verwechseln mit Xarelto. Xarelto ist eine orale Anticoagulation. Wann nimmt man Xarelto ein?
Warum nehmen alte Leute, die zu ihnen in die Praxis kommen oder in die Dinge Xarelto ein?
Vorhoffnima. Jawohl, genau, das ist alle erste, was die haben. Jetzt gucken wir mal,
sie hat gesagt vor zwei Jahren hat man mich schlafen gelegt und haben Schock abgegeben.
Und dann hat es noch Xarelto in der Medikation. Da kann man schon überlegen,
hätten sie fahren können, warum nehmen sie dann Xarelto ein? Dann hätte ihr sie
ihnen gesagt, ich habe eine Rhythmusstörung. Dann hätten sie genau gewusst,
dass vorhoffnima hat sie schon mindestens zwei Jahre, warum, weil sie vor zwei Jahren schon eine
Kardivation hatte. Stehen Sie, was ich meine, vorhoffnima. Warum nimmt man noch Anticoagulation?
Das heißt, wenn der Patient sagt, ich nehme Xarelto ein, dann fragen sie immer, warum nehmen sie
das ein? Erster Grund, vorhoffnima. Zweiter Grund, deswegen. Könnte sie das einnehmen. Warum geben
wir Orale, Anticoagulation und Warn bei welchen Patienten? Sehr gut, Trombose. Was macht Trombose
nämlich noch, das auch Luftnot machen kann? Embolie. Was für eine Embolie? Pulmonale. Lungenembolie,
sehr gut. Pulmonale, Tele-Embolie. Was also? Lungenembolie. Das heißt, dann hätten sie fragen
können, dann hätten sie schon gewusst, wenn sie schon mal eine Lungenembolie hat, es kann
sein, dass sie jetzt wieder eine Lungenembolie hat. Wenn sie aber wissen, sie hat schon mal
einen Flug, wenn man hat und hat jetzt wieder Herz, Raus und Luftnot, dann können sie in eine
andere Richtung denken. Also die zwei Sachen zum Beispiel. Kann man ja mal fragen. Okay, weiter.
Eine soziale Anamnese zeigt sich, sie sei verheiratet und lebt mit ihrem Mann. Die
Samen hat eine gesunde Tochter, reise anamnese, knochtfällig. Aus den anamnistischen Angaben gehe ich
von einem Verdacht auf Herzinsuffizienz aus. Die Fernseher, die ja nöstisch kommen, Lungenembolie oder
ein Kochschub in der Tracht. Ein Was? Oder ein Lungenkrebs. Noch mal. Also, an amnestisch kommen,
was sind Frage? Herzinsuffizienz? Herzinsuffizienz? Was noch? Lungenembolie. Lungenembolie, was noch?
Vorhofflemann. Vorhofflemann. Okay, was ist bei ihr die wahrscheinlichste, die wahrscheinlichste
Diagnose? Jetzt, wo wir das alles zusammen besprochen haben. Wahrscheinlichste Lungenembolie. Nein. Nein.
Warum ist die wahrscheinlichste? Aber dann natürlich, das Problem ist, Büßpneu ist wirklich eine
schwierige Diagnose. Ehrlich, ich habe etwas Schweres genommen bei ihm und ich habe extra ganz wenig
erzählt. Also, sie hat gesagt, sie hat schon mal eine Kategorie Version gehabt, sie hat jetzt Herzkrasen.
Ich habe extra am Anfang nicht Herzkrasen gesagt, weil es zu einfach gewesen wäre. Sie hat jetzt
wieder Herzkrasen, Beklemmung und Luftnot. Okay? Und vor zwei Jahren hat sie eine Kategorie
Version gehabt und hat Antikorglutton. Die meisten Patienten sind wieder Klara. Die meisten Patienten,
die noch mal kommen, haben möglicherweise eine Tachiarutinie absoluter wieder. Tachikardis
hofflemmern oder hofflattern, was auch immer. Wir wissen es ja nicht, es wird wahrscheinlich hofflemmern,
hofflattern sein, meistens hofflemmern. Und sind da drunter KADialdekompensiert. Also,
sind sie mit der Diagnose-Herzen-Fizenz gar nicht falsch. Möglicherweise ist die KADialdekompensiert
im Rahmen eines erneuten Tachikarden-Profliemmern. Ist das logisch für Sie? Trotzdem haben sie
absolut recht. Also Herz- und Sozienskonfizient. Warum? Weil sie jetzt tagt über diese Kröchlöderme,
sie steht nachts zweimal auf zum Tippy machen. Sie hat Luftnot und sie hat Engelgefühl,
kann auch einfach eine KADialdekompensation, kann einfach Herz- und Soziens sein. Was kann
es noch sein? Sie hat gesagt, sie hat schon mal eine Kategie-Untersuchung gehabt. Sie hat
Engelgefühl und Luftnot. Das kann natürlich auch was sein. Auch ein Hemai sein. Richtig,
es kann auch eine Mio-Kad-Infarkt sein oder einfach eine KHK. Sagen Sie einfach Mio-Kad-Infarkt,
KHK, das ist, man will sagen, keine typische, also Druckgefühl auf der Brust jetzt, so wie
sie das befand. Ja, muss man auch ausschließen. Sehr gut, genau. Das kommt als zweites
in Frage bei ihr. Herz- und Soziens zum Beispiel sehr gut. KADialdekompensation, Herz- und Soziens.
Muss man noch herausfinden, warum die Herz- und Soziens-KADialdekompensation, wir haben
jetzt gesagt, absolut, das ist bei Fuff-Liemann möglicherweise als Ursache. Drittens haben
wir gesagt, was haben wir jetzt gesagt nochmal? Lune, moly, fau, Fuff-Liemann, Korne, Herz-krank.
Coronare, Herz- und Kein, haben wir gesagt. Genau, Ichemi, haben wir gesagt,
kann jetzt auch Problem sein, Mio-Kad-Infarkt, die Beschwerden. Und als, als, jetzt ist es jetzt,
was man noch überlegen müsste, jetzt gucken Sie mal, sie hat gesagt, sie hat Schwindel,
wenn sie sich körperlich anstrengt. Sie hat Engelgefühl, wenn sie sich körperlich anstrengt.
Und sie hat schon seit Monaten auch Düstene, wenn sie sich körperlich anstrengt. Passt
alles, Herz- und Soziens, KHK, ne, auf jeden Fall und Fuff-Liemann, Tachy-Kadis-Fuff. Aber
was passt das auch noch? Diese Trias, Engelgefühl, Schwindel und Luftnot. Was sind diese
typischen Trias? Zu welcher Krankheit passt das noch? Verorfenklappenstehnose, Verorfenklappenstehnose.
Ganz typisch bei älteren Leuten, ne. Ich meine, die ist 68 Jahre alt, die ist ja fast 70,
ne, sie ist jetzt nicht so alt, aber trotzdem passt, ne. Und das kann man ganz einfach
diagnostizieren, wenn du Stethoskop einfach mal draufsetzt, ne. Zweiter ICR, links, rechts,
dann hat man dieses Systoolikum, ne. Okay. Und Logenemboli haben sie gesagt. Sie hat jetzt keine
einenseitige Schwellung am Bein gehabt, das haben sie extra gefragt, ne. Sie haben gesagt,
welches Bein? Beide Beine? Schwellung? Ja, nein, ne. Kann aber trotzdem noch sein. Aber das
würde ich als letztere Diagnose bei ihr nehmen, ne. Ich würde, so wie sie es gemacht haben,
Herz- und Soziens. Logenemboli ist nicht so ganz wahrscheinlich bei ihr erst mal. Dann würde
ich sagen und auch dieses, dieses, dieses Katsynom der Lunge. Das würde ich sagen, aber ganz, ganz
im Schluss, ne. Die Wichtigsten bei ihr sind Herz- und Soziens-Kardal-Dekonfensation,
Kardalversion, Taryarutmie, Vorhofflemann, KHK, Zustand nach, herzkartierter Untersuchung, ne,
dass sie da was hat, Korbofunde besorgen und dann Ortenklappenschkenose, Logenemboli
und so weiter und so fort. Sehr gut. Okay. Und was machen Sie jetzt mit der Patientin?
Jetzt bringen Sie das jetzt alles ganz schnell raus, was sich für Probleme hat.
Soll ich erklären oder gehen wir Diagnose?
Ich würde meinen eigenen Verdacht so bestätigen, würde ich diese Untersuchungen durchführen,
erst mal ein EKG natürlich und danach werde ich wieder ein Parameter messen, dann nehme ich
Blut ab und Laborentersuchungen machen. Die Teilparameter haben Sie so fortgeschritten am Anfang, ne?
Wir machen ein EKG. Ja, EKG. Genau. Und im EKG können Sie schon mal sehen, ob eine Züge
eine Ergutmie ist oder eine Myokartienfaktion. Sagen Sie es, genau, sagen Sie es bitte. Ja?
Ja. Was sehen Sie im EKG? Neubechleinde, Schenkel-Glux. Ja, aber was wollen Sie jetzt vor allen Dingen
sehen beim EKG vor allen Dingen, wenn Sie denken, das ist ein Profilmann, ist das
Sehntee, ne? Sie sehen, ob das ein Profilmann ist. Ja, Tachel-Farutmie.
Sie sehen Sie, was noch? Myokartinfarkt natürlich, das ist das Erste, was wir sehen wollen, ne?
Haben Sie ja schon gesagt eben. Ja. Was sehen Sie? Lungenembuli. Was sieht man beim Myokartinfarkt,
ST-Hebungen, ne? Oder ST-Senkungen? Ja. Und bei der Lungenembuli, was sieht man da?
Das ist mir entgangen jetzt, aber kann man auch etwas... Ja, kann man wirklich sehen.
Gucken Sie mal, beim Vorhofflimmern ist das Herz-Tarikat, ne? Schnell. Also, schneller auf jeden Fall als 120, mal 30, mal 40,
bis zu 170, ne? Schneller sogar, ne? Ja. Beim Vorhofflimmern, ne?
So, wenn die Vorhofflimmern haben, haben die so ungefähr eine Frequenz von 140 bis 180.
Aber die sind unregelmäßig. Bei der Lungenembuli haben die eine Sinus-Tarikati.
Die haben einen Sinus-Rhythmus und sind schnell. Ja? So ungefähr, ja, so um die Maximale so 120, so 130 sind.
Also Sinus-Tarikati einfach, ja? Und die haben ein, was haben die, was können die noch haben?
Typisches Zeichen für eine Lungenembuli ist eine Sinus-Tarikati und typisches Zeichen ist, was noch,
eine Lungenembuli, ein Rechtschenkelblock. Wenn Sie die Kombination, Rechtschenkelblock plus Tachikati
und Sinus-Tarikati sehen, dann möchten Sie immer, immer hellhörig werden und denken, ah,
ich hab Luftnot, das könnte auch eine Lungenembuli sein, ne? Es sei denn, Sie haben eine Tachiarhythmie,
ne? Dann wissen Sie ganz genau, was die Ursache ist, ne? Dann ist das jede eine Tachiarhythmie
einfach fertig, oft. Oder hat es Dehebungen. Okay? Okay, das heißt mit dem EKG haben Sie
schon mal ausgeschlossen, ob es eine Tachiarhythmie ist. Wenn es ein Sinus-Rhythmus ist
und der Katzen hat immer noch Luftnot, kann es kein Hofkliman sein, die Ursache. Ja? Okay,
dann haben Sie Labor gemacht, was machen Sie im Labor? Was bestimmen Sie im Labor?
Erst mal Herz und Siemen. Zika, Zika-MB, Troponin, Myoglobin. Nein, kein Myoglobin. No.
Und Litroponin, Zika und Zika-MB. Okay. Und der, die mehr um eine Lungenembuli aufzuschließen,
da. Ja, gut, genau. Und was kann man noch machen? Was kann man noch bestimmen,
so als man bestimmt im Labor BNP, ne? Im Labor, meinen Sie? Im Labor, pro BNP noch.
Da wissen Sie, ob der eine Herzinfizient hat oder nicht, ne? Rechtsherzbelastung zum
Beispiel. Herzschwäche, ne? Wenn es pro BNP erhöht ist. Auch würde ich ein Herzecho
durchführen, um ein Hochherz-Rechtsherzbelastung zu bestimmen. Auszuschließen, genau.
Zu sehen, auszuschließen, genau. Um auszuschließen, Rechtsherzbelastung
auszuschließen, können Sie auf jeden Fall sehr gut Echoes zuckern. Und was noch,
was sieht man im Echo noch? Im Echo. Im Echo, können Sie sehen, ob der Rest
der Zeit ist. Perjektion, Traffition, Werte messen. Ja, Sie können die Pumfung
funktionen, messen. Fragen Sie einfach Pumfung, ne? Bestimmen vom Herzen,
durch die EF. Sie können die Pumfung funktionen, messen. Was haben Sie dann
bestimmt, wenn Sie die Pumfung funktionen, haben? Was wissen Sie dann?
Es zeigt ein Myokartinfarkt. Nein. Pumfung funktionen, zeigt nicht
Myokartinfarkt, immer. Nein. Pumfung funktionen, haben Sie erst mal die
Herzschwäche. Könnte sein. Haben Sie, haben die Herzschwäche
ausgeschlossen, mit der Pumfung funktionen, okay? Könnte, genau,
könnte warum? Genau, aber es könnte auch sein, dass denn eine
Einschaltung der Pumfung passen hat, dass es ich hier im Späding
ist, ne? Absolut richtig, absolut richtig, aber dann haben die auch
Wandbewegung störern, okay? Wandbewegung störern.
Wir können auch beurteilen, Herz, Wand.
Das sind Abschnitte, die Wandabschnitte. Sagt ich doch, das sind die
Wandabschnitte. Man sieht die Wandabschnitte, Wandbewegung
störern, Wandabschnitte. Wandabschnitte, ob die gut
bewegend ist. Also man sieht, man sieht sehr gut gesagt,
Rechts-Selbstbelastungszeichen, man sieht die Pumfung
funktionen, Herzschwäche, man sieht, anhand der Pumfung
funktionen und Wandbewegung störern, ob da ein Herzschwäche
ist, eine Herz-Kreins-Gesäßerkrankung vorliegt,
nicht ischemische Herzerkrankung vorliegt. Und, was noch,
was war unsere Differenzialdiagnose noch, was könnte es
noch sein? Was haben wir noch im Echo? Was habe ich
gesagt? Ah, klappen. Ja, das ist richtig, man sieht die
Aorten, die klappen. Das sind wirklich, das ist eine
super Untersuchung, die es ja im Kardikrat geht, wo sie
Pumfung funktionen, die klappen das rechte Herz
beurteilen können. Ist das nicht toll? Dann haben Sie mit
einer Versuchung schon so viel aufgeschlossen, wenn Sie dazu
noch passend das X-PG haben und dann noch das Laubord,
dann können Sie sagen, der Patient hat das fertig. Okay,
alles klar. Ein Röntgen an Torax ist erforderlich, oder?
Auf jeden Fall, finde ich sehr gut, weil dann sehen Sie,
ob der Patient was hat. Das sehen wir, die Infiltraten,
oder? Aber es geht jetzt nicht um Infiltrate, wenn
sie Luftnot hat vor allen Dingen, ne? Wir gehen ja
wovon aus. Sie haben gesagt, eine Herzschweigrösserung.
Und, was vor allen Dingen, was wollen Sie sehen?
Herzbegrüßung sehe ich auch im Echo. Was wollen Sie sehen
im Röntgen? Wasser, Stau, TV Stau. Ob der Patient
Wasser in der Lunge hat. TV Stau. Okay? Weil den
Plurre August, den sieht man am besten, wenn sie
mit dem Echo fertig sind mit dem Ultrastrahl. Das mache
ich dann bei den Patienten, die Luftnot haben.
Dann sieht man dann die Auguste.
Ja. Und gegebenenfalls auch eine Angiografie, aber...
Herzkatheteruntersuchung, meinen Sie? Ja. Das sind
Sachen, die hängen davon ab, was dann in Labor
rauskommt. Also, CK, CK-ND, Troponien, Echo.
Je nachdem, was da rauskommt, kann man dann
natürlich auf jeden Fall im Vergleich dann
auf eventuell noch mehr Herzkatheteruntersuchung
machen. Sehr gut wiederholen, ne? Weil die
andere ist zu lange her. Und man muss vor
allen Dingen die Vorbefunde holen, von
damals, ne? Und gucken, was daraus gekommen
ist. Ja? Im Telaf. Richtig, genau. Was
machen Sie mit der Patientin jetzt? Jetzt
möchte ich Patientin Intensivstationen einnehmen.
Nein, muss nicht auf Intensivstation. Sie
muss auf eine Überwachungstation. Sagen Sie
einfach nur stationär aufnehmen? Ja, ich
muss stationär aufgenommen werden. Sie machen
sofort Sauerstoff dran, bei den Nasensälen.
Sauerstoff zuvor. Sauerstoffgabe.
Zufuhr, Sauerstoffgabe, sehr gut, Sauerstoffgabe,
stationäre Aufnahme, Sauerstoffgabe, was
noch. Analyte. Kannst einfach etwas, was
Sie sofort machen können. Nee, was können
Sie geben, wenn Sie sagen Herzinsuffizienz.
Das ist das Erste, was Sie geben, das
Patienten schon hilft. Lasix,
Juratikum, IV. Ja.
Introdenus, Juratikum. Jetzt, welche
Diagnose geben wir ein? Was, von welcher Diagnose
nein, noch einmal. Was haben Sie jetzt
gesagt? Welche, wo geben wir die Diagnose
ein? Das ist falsch, nein. Von welcher Diagnose
gehen wir aus?
Angenommen. Welche Diagnose gehen wir
auf? Ja, genau. Genau. Also ich
meine im Kopf meine Diagnose war aber
zwar richtig, nach dem Herzinsuffizienz
zu sagen, dass sie eine kardiale
Dekompensation hat im Rahmen
dieses Tachikaden, dieser Tachikaden
Rhythmusstörung. Kardiale Dekompensation
bei Tachiarutimia absoluter bei
Bekannt- und Co. flimmern. Das war
meine Diagnose. Aber man hätte hieraus
in dieser Prüfung kann man nicht
durchfallen. Wenn man wirklich alle
Differenzialdiagnosen erklärt, wenn Sie sagen, ich
gehe von einer Herzinsuffizienz aus, weil ich
denke, das ist so und so auch gut. Wenn Sie
sagen, ich gehe von einer Logenembolie
aus, obwohl die Patienten weitseits jetzt
keine richtige Einseitgeschällung hat,
ja. Aber Sie können sagen, begründen
Sie das. Sie können sagen, Patient ist
Tachikad, ja. Und Patient hat Luftnot
und deswegen gehe ich von der Regelung,
kann man doch, also man kann hier nicht
durchfallen in dieser Prüfung. Wenn man das
alles gut begründet und Sie haben das
also Sie sprechen sehr gut Deutsch, haben
Sie super gemacht, aber nicht durchfallen.
Aber ein bisschen mutiger, Sie können das doch.
Nicht so schüchtern, weil Sie machen das gut.
Ja, danke schön. Ich war ein bisschen
untergefallen, aber jetzt also...
Was heißt untergefallen? Noch mal.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ich meine, ne.
Was meinen Sie damit? Nein,
was meinen Sie damit?
Untergefallen. Was heißt das?
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ein bisschen Modum düşt.
Ich war ein bisschen...
Depressionen,
Hastalarin, da hat sie so ein
Wort genutzt.
Ich habe es getroffen.
Was meinst du, was meinst du?
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das sagt.
Das Modul ist nicht schlecht,
könnte ich nicht um mich zu machen? Nein.
Okay, alles klar.